OKAY WE'RE GONNA BRING THIS
MEETING TO ORDER WELCOME
EVERYONE. ON THE TO THE
ASSEMBLY GEO COMMITTEE.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A CORE A
QUORUM I HEAR SO SECRETARY
PLEASE SIR CALL THE ROLL
ESTABLISHED FOR. GRAY. HAIR
BIGELOW.
ACOSTA HERE.
AND WE ARE CURRY.
BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY
HERE.
COOPER HERE.
DALY.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON.
GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER. KILEY.
LACKEY HERE. LIVING.
LOW.
RUBIO.
SILAS.
WALDRON.
OKAY WERE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
WILL BEGIN BY WELCOMING A TWO
NEW MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IS
SELLING AND KILEY. AND SEVERAL
LACKEY WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY.
MR KHALID WOULD LIKE A WELCOME
BACK WELCOME BACK MR CHO.
HOPEFULLY WON'T BE TAKING ANY
MORE TRIP SOON.
MEMBERS THIS TIME WILL. GO AHEAD
AND TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREG. AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA BY ACOSTA AYE
AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY AYE
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE COOPER AYE
DALY.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON. GLORIA. GLORIA AYE JONES
SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LOW.
RUBIO.
SILAS.
MISS RUBIO WAS HERE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADD ON TO THE CONCERT
COUNTY.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SO THIS AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON HIGH.
OKAY THE CONSENT CONNECT
COUNTERS BEEN ADOPTED AND AT
THIS POINT MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO
ITEM ONE ON THE AGENDA AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER LONG PLEASE.
APPROACH AND OUR PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
I AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES BOTH STATE AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
COMMUNICATION TO INCLUDE CLEAR.
TRANSLATION FOR THE MOST
COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH IN IMPACTED COUNTY
OR COUNTIES.
WITH FORTY FOUR PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIANS OVER THE AGES.
I'M SORRY ARE OVER THE AGE OF
FIVE SPEAKING A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH AT HOME IT'S VITAL
THAT EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS
ARE MADE AVAILABLE IN LANGUAGES
OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
THE KALAYEH S. OFFICE FOR AXIS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EAT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IDENTIFYING THE EMERGENCY
CONCERNS A POPULATIONS WITH.
AXIS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER A DISASTER
DESPITE THE FACT THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING ARE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY ARE INCLUDED IN
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEED
CONSIDERATIONS. EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS ARE STILL NOT
REQUIRED TO BE AMENABLE IN NINE
WHICH IS OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
AS.
COMMUNITIES IN DISTRICTS
EXPERIENCE.
FIRST HAND BY THE IT BY THE
IMPACT OF EXCLUSIVE EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION DURING THE
DEVASTATING THOMAS FIRE.
WHICH BURNED OVER TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND ACRES IN
FORCE OVER A HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND RESIDENTS TO EVACUATE.
DURING THE INITIAL DAYS THE
THOMAS FIRE THERE WERE
UNDERSTANDABLE COMMUNICATION
GAPS.
BUT SCHEDULED SPANISH EMERGENCY
UPDATES TOOK OVER A WEEK TO BE
PROVIDED FROM THE DATE OF THE
FIRE INITIALLY STARTED THIS LEFT
MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS FEELING
AND SAFE AND UNSURE WHETHER TO
EVACUATE. THE COMMUNICATION
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS THAT SPEAK
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH ARE
NOT BEING SUFFICIENTLY
INCORPORATED INTO EMERGENCY
PLAN.
THIS OVERSIGHT PLACES THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING FIRST RESPONDERS AT
RESTORING TIMES WHEN EFFICIENT
COMMUNICATION IS MOST NEEDED. I
HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
INDIVIDUALS AT WHO WILL TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL JENNA BE
FLOOR IS HARO AND FROM THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF MY*
AND ALSO AGAIN UROS WITH THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA MOVE THE
BILL.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
MANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ALSO BE
HELPED THE CITY'S GENERAL TO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN THE
EARLY HOURS AND DAYS AND WEEKS
THE TUBS FIRE. WAS OUR THAT WE
HAD A NUMBER OF STAFF AND FOLKS
IN SANTA ROSA WE'RE WORKING TO
TRANSLATE EMERGENCY%
COMMUNICATIONS MESSAGES.
WE GOT TREMENDOUS SUPPORT FROM
OH YES BUT ONE OF THE LESSONS
THAT WE'VE LEARNED IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN GET THE COMMUNICATION
ALPINE TIME INTO. IN A MANNER
WHICH EVERYONE IN OUR COMMUNITY
IN ALL LANGUAGES ARE GETTING THE
MESSAGE THAT THEY NEED WE THINK
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP ON THE SPELL AND THEREFORE
WE ASK FOR YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY.
.
FURTHER TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE A TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION.
MARY CHRIS AT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO MORE TESTIMONIAL RAY
BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS.
A BIG. THANK YOU MISS LAMONT ON
PRE* WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE COMING FROM.
I DISTRICT THAT HAS A LOT OF
BILINGUAL ACTIVITIES
I IT IT MEANS A LOT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME I HAVE TO AS.
SOME QUESTIONS LIKE WHAT IS THE
MATRIX
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO ESTABLISH.
IDENTIFYING YOU KNOW WHAT
BECOMES THE PREDOMINANT
LANGUAGE.
BECAUSE IN MANY CASES THAT COULD
BE ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
OR THE THIRD LANGUAGE THEREFORE
ALL IN NOTICES WOULD GO OUT AND.
HOW WE GONNA HANDLE?
THE COMBINED EFFORTS SO WHAT
WOULD BE THAT MATRIX FOR THAT I
GOT SEVERAL QUESTIONS OKAY SO
WELL ACTUALLY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAD. ENGLISH WILL ALWAYS
BE THAT WERE THE PRIMARY
LANGUAGE AND SO THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO ENGLISH AND SO THAT
FORTY FOUR PERCENT NUMBER WE
HAVE ACTUALLY CAME FROM THE
TWENTY TEN. US CENSUS AND SO
THAT'S WHERE WE KNOW ALL OF THE
COUNTIES HAVE THAT INFORMATION
AND WE ALSO HAD TO HAVE AN IDEA
THAT WE WILL TAKE AYE IF THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD. AYE TODAY
WILL TAKE TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE
WHICH IS A PREPARATION THAT IT
SHOULD BE EITHER TRANSLATION AND
OR. ON A LANGUAGE ASSESSMENT
BECAUSE WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA MAY HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS
WE KNOW THERE ARE SOME COUNTIES
WHERE. I YOU KNOW OF SPANISH MAY
BE ONE OF THEM BUT IT'S UP THERE
WITH A DIFFERENT LANGUAGE.
AND SO THEY MAY NEED TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT RESPONSE OF THE IDEA
IT IS REALLY THAT THE COUNTIES
WILL HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER A SIMPLE
TRANSLATION ON EVERYTHING IS
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED TO DO OR.
THEY WILL INCLUDE AND LANGUAGE
ASSESSMENT AS PART OF THEIR
EMERGENCY PLAN AND THAT LANGUAGE
ASSESSMENT WILL HAVE WHATEVER
SPECIFIC NEED GAMINI IDENTIFY
FOR EXACT COUNT.
SO HELP WALK US THROUGH.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE TWENTY
TEN CENTS IS WE'RE JUST AROUND
THE CORNER FROM AND WHEN HE
TWENTY.
CENSUS AND THAT WILL BE.
HOW FOR REFERENCES BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WERE VERY CLOSE I
HAD?
?
ARE WE GONNA WANNA.
DO THIS TWICE.
BASING IT OFF OF THE TWENTY TEN
AND THEN.
BUT AGAIN HAVE TO REALLY CHANGE
THINGS AND GO TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE.
SINCE THIS YEAH I WOULD LOVE FOR
THERE TO BE NO MORE NATURAL
DISASTERS ON BETWEEN NOW AND THE
NEXT CENSUS THAT WOULD BE MY
DREAM. ON BUT HAVING LIVED THIS
I THINK THAT THERE IS AN URGENCY
TO DO SOMETHING NOW AND THESE
EMERGENCY PLANS ARE SOMETHING
THAT COUNTIES ACTUALLY.
HAVE TO CONDUCT AN UPDATE ON A
REGULAR BASIS SO THIS WOULD BE
ONE MORE ELEMENT THAT THEY WOULD
INCLUDE IN THAT EMERGENCY PLAN
TO IDENTIFY HOW THEY WILL GET
THAT INFORMATION OUT BUT YES. ON
THAT THE PLAN IS TO DO IT RIGHT
AWAY BUT IN ADDITION ON UPDATE
THAT INFORMATION THAT COUNTIES
WILL GENERALLY UPDATE ALL OF
THEIR COUNTY INFORMATION TO
INCLUDE THE TWENTY. FIVE TWENTY
CENSUS SO WITH THAT LET'S GO TO
THE COUNTY BY COUNTY.
BECAUSE IN SOME CASES DURING THE
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS TRAILS AND
HAVING WRITTEN SOME OF THOSE
MIDDLE PART OF IT.
.
I KNOW THAT IN SOME CASES WE
HAVE TO MAKE THE ASSUMPTION
THAT.
THE LOCAL COUNTY CAN'T TAKE CARE
OF ITSELF THERE FOR ALL SYSTEMS
ARE DOWN WHIP RUN THE NEXT.
NEIGHBORING COUNTY IN A
NEIGHBORING COUNTY MAY NOT HAVE
A SYSTEM THAT'S DESIGNED TO THE
SAME LANGUAGE CAPABILITIES
BECAUSE IT'S.
DENNIS MODELING HUMAN HASN'T
COME OUT THAT WAY.
HOW ARE WE GONNA REMEDY THAT ANY
CASE THAT FAILS AS WELL THEN
THERE'S THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHICH HAS THE THIRD
OVERLAY IN THE SYSTEM?
AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE ANY OF
THIS SO HOW ARE WE GOING TO
COORDINATE THAT NOW BECAUSE IT'S
NOT REALLY CLEAR.
RIGHT IN AND AND AND ACTUALLY I
WILL SAY THAT IN THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE DO SO
WHAT WE LEARNED WITH THE THOMAS
FIRE AND THE DEGREE FLOWS.
IS THAT THE THE CHALLENGE WAS
NOT THAT WE DIDN'T IDENTIFY THAT
THIS THAT CRITICAL TRANSLATED
LANGUAGE WAS NEEDED IT WAS THAT
IT WASN'T PART OF THE
COORDINATION SO THIS BILL WOULD
FORCE IT TO BE PART OF THE
COORDINATION. AND THE EVERY
COUNTY WOULD HAVE AND I THINK
THAT IF THE COUNTY DOES HAVE TO
GO TO ANOTHER COUNTY THAT WILL
ALSO BE PART OF THE
CONSIDERATION WHAT WHAT
SERVICES.
I DO THE OTHER COUNTIES HAVE
WHAT IS THEIR PLAN HAVE ON IT
FROM WORKING IT KIND OF ON THE
GROUND WITH FOLKS I REALIZED.
THAT IT WAS RELEASED A SIMPLE
KIND OF JUST LET'S GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT SO I REMEMBER.
WHEN CAL FIRE STARTED GIVING
OUT THE INFORMATION THE
SCHEDULED WEEKLY SIX O'CLOCK
NEWS.
ONLINE CONFERENCES IN SPANISH
BECAUSE THEY DID HAVE SOMEONE
WHO COULD SPEAK SPANISH BUT IT
WAS A LITTLE BIT OF AN
AFTERTHOUGHT AND THAT BECAME
REALLY CHALLENGING BECAUSE IN
THE MOMENT. OF NEED OF
EVACUATIONS AYE MEANS WRONG.
WHAT WHEN YOU TRANSLATE FOR
EXAMPLE?
ST THAT'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO TRANSLATE
IT STREET THERE IS NOTHING WHAT
THE TRANSLATED NAME AND SO WE
REALIZED IT WAS CREATING MORE OF
A PROBLEM AND IT'S A SAFETY
ISSUE FOR EVERYONE. SO I THINK
THAT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
SAYS YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
TRANSLATE ALL THE INFORMATION IF
THERE IS IF THE HIGHEST DOESN'T
WORK FOR A COUNTY THEN YOU
DUELING WITH YOU. ON THIS WILL
BE THE AMENDMENT WE TAKE TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE SHOULD THIS MOVE
FORWARD THEN YOU WOULD YOU A
LANGUAGE ASSESSMENT AND THAT
LANGUAGE ASSESSMENT WOULD
CLEARLY PROVIDE THE STEP BY STEP
OF WHAT BACK COUNTY NEEDS TO DO.
TO RESPOND TO ALL OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS
AND AND THAT'S GOOD TO KNOW THAT
THERE'S AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE TAKING OF ARE
PRESENTING. AND THAT'S WHAT THE
NEXT STEP
SO YOU KNOW AS I SAID WHEN I
STARTED OUT.
.
I LIKE WHAT I'M SEEING AND I
COULD FEEL IT YOU KNOW THIS BILL
IN ANOTHER BILL ARE A COUPLE OF
BILLS I HAVE TO.
NOT VOTE ON TODAY BECAUSE OFF
HERE AGAIN IN THE.
I SIMPLY IDEA APPROPRIATIONS.
CITED EQUATION SO I CAN'T.
REALLY.
GET AHEAD OF MYSELF I SOMETIMES.
ANYWAY I COULD I WOULD RECOMMEND
A SUPPORT FOR THIS ON THE RIGHT
NOW TODAY I'M JUST GOING TO.
ANON VOTE NOT LEAVE THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF.
SUPPORT IT AS IT MOVES FOR IT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
QUESTIONS.
MS I WEAR CURRY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING THIS FOR I
AM GLAD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS ITEM.
WE LEARNED OUR LESSON FIRST AND
I FIRST THING YOU DID IS PICKED
UP THE PHONE BILL MONIQUE THIS
IS THE NUMBER ONE THING WE GOTTA
DO IS MAKE SURE THE TRANSLATIONS
ARE BECAUSE THE FIRST THING THE
PEOPLE WERE VERY CRITICAL OF. OF
BUT ASSUMING THE WE WERE BEING
RESPONSIVE WHICH WAS SO FAR FROM
THE TRUTH. NEVERTHELESS IS THAT
I THINK THIS IS GOOD LEGISLATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
UP FOR. AND I DO THINK YOU
BECAUSE WITHIN THE FIRST TWENTY
FOUR HOURS OF THE EMERGENCY AND
ENTER AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
YOU DID CALL AND YOU SAID
EXACTLY THIS WOULD HAPPEN AND IT
DID SO I THINK YOU FOR THAT.
OKAY DO EVERY OTHER OUR QUESTION
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND. THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GRAY AYE GRAY AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING ACOSTA I.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY. AYE WE
ARE CURRY AYE BERMAN. BERMAN AYE
BONTA. COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
UBER AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA. YEAH.
YOU SEE I.
GALLAGHER I. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA HIGH.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY LIKE LACKEY AYE
LEVINE. LEVINE AYE LOW.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I SAW THIS.
SO THIS AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NINE ON
THE AGENDA AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR AND. ASK A CELL EVER
STEINORTH TO PLEASE APPROACH
PRESENT HIS BILL.
WELCOME SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
THE PROTECT OUR HOMES PILOT
PROGRAM OULD ALLEVIATE HARDSHIP
ON STRUGGLING CALIFORNIANS WHO
MUST CHOOSE BETWEEN BASIC NEEDS
AND HOME SECURITY.
SAFETY OF ONE'S OWN HOME SHOULD
NOT BE ONE OF THOSE COMPETING
NEEDS.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
THREE THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FOR THE
PROTECT OUR HOMES PILOT PROGRAM
WOULD PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE EITC THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT AND MERCED AND
SAMMY DINO COUNTIES. WITH GRANTS
UP TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FROM
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
IN ORDER TO PURCHASE QUALIFYING
HOME SECURITY EQUIPMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OVER A
MILLION PROPERTY CRIMES WERE
COMMITTED.
STUDIES SHOW THAT BURGLARIES
OCCUR MOST COMMONLY AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WITH HIGH
RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT LEAVING
RESIDENTS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO BURGLARY.
ONE STUDY FOUND THAT EIGHTY
THREE PERCENT OF CONVICTED
BURGLARS WOULD ATTEMPT TO
DETERMINE IF A SECURITY SYSTEM
WAS PRESIDENT PRIOR TO
ATTEMPTING A BURGLARY.
ONCE FOUND TO BE DEFENSELESS
THIRTY PERCENT OF POLLED
CONVICTED BURGLARS RE ENTERED A
HOMER BUILT THING THEY
PREVIOUSLY BURGLARIZED.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THE
SECURITY SYSTEMS COST UPWARDS OF
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS FORCING
RESIDENTS LIVING NEAR THE
POVERTY LINE TO MAKE THE CHOICE
BETWEEN HOME SAFETY. AND OTHER
BASIC NEEDS.
AND MERCED AND SAMMY DINO
COUNTIES BETWEEN SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE PERCENT OF RESIDENTS
LIVING IN POVERTY.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY.
TESTIMONY.
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING THAT ANY TESTIMONY NOT
POSITION.
SEEING NONE AND QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS MISTER SOLACE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY DO SEE A NEED FOR THIS
SPECIALLY IN THOSE AREAS OF HIGH
CRIME.
PLACES THAT HAVE DOUBLE DIGIT
UNEMPLOYMENT
AND AYE DID SEE THE. SAY THAT
YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
MET AMENDMENTS OF WAS JUST
WANTED TO ASK IF YOU TO ACCEPT
ANOTHER AMENDMENT TO CLERK
CURRENT IN KINGS COUNTY.
A I I AM ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE
IDEA OF INCLUDING KINGS COUNTY
ABSOLUTELY CURRENT KINGS COUNTY
SO HE'LL DISCUSS THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
WITHOUT ALL SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHICH CURRENTLY.
BECAUSE CHAIRMAN.
IT THANK YOU.
SOME NEVER SIGNED WITH FOR THE
LEGISLATURE I WAS CURES AND SO
WERE STABBED TO PROGRAMS THAT'S
THE REASON FOR A. PILOT RIGHT
YOU.
TO TEST OUT THE COP CONCEPT CHAU
GOES RIGHT. AND YOU HAVE BUSY
PART OF A WIDE ARRAY OF
SECURITY.
.
OPTIONS I MEAN. WHEN I READ THIS
ARE THINKING OF A SECURITY
SYSTEM PROBABLY ACQUIRING ONE
WOULD THAT ALSO BE INCLUSIVE OF
THE MONTHLY SERVICE THAT. WOULD
HAVE TO GO ALONG WITH THAT IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE SYSTEM YES
OKAY IN THE SECURITY FENCE IN
WHAT IS THAT ME IS THERE. KEEN
TO FIND OUT WHAT SPECIFICALLY
FROM SO SECURITY FENCING WOULD
BE DEFINED AS THE SECURITY DOORS
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE FRONT OF
PEOPLE'S HOMES SURE AND THEN
ALSO SOME OF THE PERIMETER
FENCING.
FROM LIKE DOES IT HAVE TO ME IS
LIKE IN CONVENTIONAL
NEIGHBORHOOD FENCER IS THAT IS
THAT SOMETHING MUST.
THIS MAY SEEM A LITTLE BIT OF A
PICKY BUT ANY ITEM I BARB WIRE
ME WHAT WHAT MAKES A SECURITY
FENCE OR JUST A REGULAR IT WOULD
IT WOULD BE A TRADITIONAL FANS
BUT PERHAPS THERE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL SECURITY MEASURES ON
ON THE PERIMETER. BUT THE
PRIMARY WE'RE LOOKING AT IS WHEN
YOU SEE THOSE.
SECURITY DOORS ARE YOU FAMILIAR
WITH THOSE WHERE YOU CAN'T
REALLY SEE HOW PEOPLE CAN SEE
OUT WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT AND
THEN IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
SECURITY NEEDED LET'S SAY THEY
HAVE.
AREA.
HAVE EASY PENETRATION AT THEIR
HOME.
OKAY SO WE'RE NOW LOOKING LIKE A
TRADITIONAL LIKE PICKET FENCE OR
ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE THAT
ISN'T THE INTENTION OF IT NOR IS
IT TO THE EXTENT OF OF. YOU KNOW
CONCERTINA WIRE ANYTHING OF THAT
NATURE.
AND.
.
OKAY THE.
WAS THAT WITH THE PILOT COUNTIES
THAT WERE SELECTED IS THERE ANY
COULDN'T DATA THAT SORT OF BACKS
UP THOSE SELECTIONS AND YES WHAT
WE WERE LOOKING AT IS THAT OUR
CRIME RATES OF THE POPULATION
AND THEN THE PERCENTAGE OF E. I.
T. C..
AND ALSO WAS RESPECTED TO THE.
LOCATIONS ONE WAS IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ONCE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA
SO WE'RE TRYING TO SPREAD THAT
OUT OKAY SIR MOVING THE
GEOGRAPHIC.
SOUTHERN CENTRAL KABUL IN IT BUT
MY FAMILIES HOW NO FOR EXAMPLE
TARANTINO HAS A SEVENTEEN
PERCENT.
EITC ABRADE AND ALSO HAS.
SIMILAR POVERTY AND CRIME RATES
AND THEN MERCED COUNTY WAS UP TO
TWENTY PERCENT.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT WHICH WHICH
COUNTIES HAD THE HIGHEST
PROPENSITY OF OF LOW INCOME AND
ALSO EITC COMPLIANT AND ALSO HAD
HIGH CRIME SO WE'RE COMPARING
THOSE TWO ARE THESE THE TWO
BIGGEST AND THOSE WERE THE ONES
THAT THAT DREW OUR ATTENTION TO
BUT I CAN'T SAY THAT THEY'RE.
THE TWO BIGGEST WHEN WE LOOK AT
LA COUNTY AND SOME OF THE OTHER
SISTER JESSA EXCEPTIONALLY LARGE
COUNTIES BUT THESE TWO WOULD FIT
WITHIN THE PARAMETERS WERE
LOOKING FOR THE PILOT.
.
I IMAGINE YOU HAVE NO OTHER
MEMBERS ASKED TO BE INCLUDED. IN
IN THAT OF COURSE AFFECTS COST
RIGHT WELL A COULD RIGHT NOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT A THREE MILLION
DOLLAR.
BASIC FOR THE FOR THE PILOT
PROGRAM AND PUT A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET ON THAT
SO WE WOULD BE WORKING WITH.
.
IT'S MAY WE WILL BE WORKING
WITH.
.
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
EACH INDIVIDUAL COUNTY TO PUT
TOGETHER THE PROGRAM ON HOW THEY
WOULD AND THE INDIVIDUALS WOULD
APPLY AND HOW THE MONEY WOULD BE
DISPERSED.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING THEM FOR A CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES SO THAT I HEAR YOU.
ACCEPT AN AMENDMENT TO THE
AMENDMENT A NUMBER TWO ADDING
TURNED IN KINGS COUNTY I DID.
WELL DONE.
ANYTHING.
CLARIFY THAT THERE ARE THREE
AMENDMENTS FIRST CHANGING NAME
OF PROGRAM HOMES COULD GRAB
PROGRAM TO PROTECT OUR HOMES
PILOT PROGRAM. AMENDMENT TO THE
ADDITION OF CURRENT KINGS AND
THAT OF COURSE AMENDMENTS
REPLACING A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
THAT'S CORRECT AND YOUR AGREED
TO THOSE WRITERS. VERY GOOD.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THIS IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GRAY. AYE GRAY
AYE BIGELOW VOTING BIGELOW NOT
VOTING ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY AYE
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE BONTA.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING EDUARDO
GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LIVING NO.
LOW.
RUBIO. ACT
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SO THIS AYE WALDRON.
CLOSE. OKAY WERE STATUS THAT'S
OUR CALL KIND WILL GO AHEAD
LEAVE DE.
ROLE OPEN FOR FOLKS THAT ARE
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU BACK IN THE
GEO COMMITTEE AND BEST WISHES
AHEAD PRECIADO THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A VOTE CHANGE.
EXODUS GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
ROLE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE BONTA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER.
LOW.
WALDRON.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO.
MOVE TO ITEM SEVEN ON YOUR
AGENDA THAT'SAB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY A SEVEN MEMBER MCCARTY
IS HERE IF YOU COULD APPROACH
AND PRESENT YOUR BILL SIR
.
AND MEMBERS MY FOURTH YEAR HERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY FIRST TIME IN
JAIL.
WELCOME THANK YOU SO I
REPRESENT.
CAL EXPO STATE FAIR THIS IS A A
DISTRICT ISSUE A LOCAL ISSUE.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE HARNESS THE HARNESS
RACING ASSOCIATION. TO IMPORT
ONE ADDITIONAL INTERNATIONAL
RACE PROGRAM ON DAYS WHERE THERE
IS LIFE RACING GOING ON AT OUR
STATE FAIR.
THE MEASURE WOULD PROVIDE OUR
HORSE.
RACING AND RACE TRACK PATIENTS
WITH MORE OPTIONS FOR WAGERING
DRAW LARGER CROWDS ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS OF COURSE WILL INCREASE
REVENUE FOR THE TRACK WE HAVE
AND MOST WORKERS SECOND.
THANK YOU.
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I'LL BE EXCEEDINGLY BRIEF A VERY
BROAD ON BEHALF OF GOLDEN BEAR
RACING THAT OPERATES THE RACING
THE HARNESS RACING ASSOCIATION
THE TEAMSTERS WHO REPRESENT
MEMBERS AT THE TRACK.
ON THIS WILL HELP US TONIGHT ONE
INTRODUCE CHRIS SHIP A WHO.
OPERATES THAT THE THE RACING AND
KNOWS EVERYTHING IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT ABOUT IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRAY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
CHRISTOPHER CHECK.
GOLDEN BEAR RACING.
MY PARTNER NOT BEEN KENNY AND I
WE OPERATE THE. HARNESS MEET FOR
WATCHING WAGER DOT COM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO I UNDER LEASE AT CAL
EXPO.
DISAPPEAR JUST CONCLUDING OUR
SIX YEAR OF OPERATION UP THIS
BILL UP WILL AUTHORIZE US TO
BRING IN ONE. FULL CARD OF
INTERNATIONAL HARNESS
SIMULCASTING RACING ON NIGHTS
THAT WE RACE LIVE IT WILL ALSO
ENABLE LOS AMIGOS. WHO'S OUR
NIGHT.
OUR PARTNERS SO TO SPEAK TO
IMPORT THAT SAME CARD ON NIGHTS
IT DAY RUN THAT WE DO NOT RACE.
AND THE REVENUE WILL BE SPLIT ON
ON ALL NIGHT IRRESPECTIVE OF WHO
IS THE HOST.
SO WE FEEL IT'S A GOOD BILL.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE WE HAVE A STRONG DEMAND FOR
OUR PRODUCT BOTH A ACROSS THE
NATION.
AND I ENDED ARE NATIONAL WAY FOR
OUR HARDEST PRODUCT BUT PURSE
WISE WERE WERE NOT REALLY
COMPETITIVE WITH SUBSIDIZE
VENUES THAT HAVE. MERCY KNOWS
AND SLOT MACHINES THIS BILL.
WILL PER PROVIDE ABOUT A SEVEN
PERCENT INCREASE TO OUR PURSES.
OUR IT'LL CERTAINLY HER HELP ALL
THE BRICK AND MORTARS ACROSS THE
STATE BY GIVING THEM AN
ADDITIONAL PRODUCT ABOUT ON AT
NIGHT. AND OUT WE ASK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL OUR
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING THEM WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEE NOW WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THIS IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GRAY. AYE GRAY AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA
AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
I WORKED VERY AYE BERMAN BERMAN
AYE BONTA.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON. GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER. KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOCAL.
RUBIO AYE. RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SOLIS AYE WALDRON.
WELL THEN I.
MISTER CHAIR I WAS AND I'M AND I
I WAS TALKING TO MY SEAT MATE
HERE FROM AND I.
COOLEY.
SINCE FALL MISTER BERMAN'S FOR
LAST. WE WERE COMPARING HORSE
RACING STORIES HERE.
WELL.
ROOSTER MCCURRY WELCOME TO YOUR
FIRST TRIP TO GEO PLEASE COME
AGAIN THAT BILLS OUT.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS IT THIS
JUNCTURE WE HAVE ON THE REST THE
AUTHORS ON THE AGENDA ARE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND.
WE WILL ASK MISS AG WE ARE CURRY
IF SHE'S PREPARED TO PRESENT.
TWO ITEMS ITEM EIGHT NINE AND
FOURTEEN LET'S BEGIN WITH ITEM
EIGHT.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY TWO.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY TWO
NARROWLY UPDATES TIED HOUSE LAW
TO COME ACCOMMODATE THE
WIDESPREAD USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA
TODAY.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW A WINE
MAKER OR WINE GROWER TO INCLUDE
A PITCHER OF ANY BETS SPACE OR
RESTAURANT. IN A POST
INFORMATION ABOUT THE AND UP
HERE UPCOMING SPECIAL EVENT LIKE
A WINEMAKERS DINNER OR A WINE
TASTING.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS IS
PROHIBITED.
POSTING A PICTURE IS A MUCH MORE
DESCRIPTIVE IN AYE HATCHING WAY
FOR WINE MAKERS TO PROVE PROMOTE
THEIR OWN WINE AND EVENTS.
WHEN THERE ARE LIMITATIONS ON
WHAT CAN BE AFFECTED ONLINE
VERSION OF THE SECOND IT TAKES
AWAY FROM THE ABILITY FOR ME TO
FINISH THE SPEECH.
BUT.
I A SCREWDRIVER.
TIM WENT ON BEHALF OF THE NAPA
VALLEY VINTNERS APOLOGIES TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR NOT GETTING OUR
LETTER IN ON TIME BUT WE ARE
SUPPORT OF.
LEADERSHIP.
OKAY OTHER TESTIMNY IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA WATER ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THINK.
Q. ANY.
FURTHER TESTS MIND SUPPORTER.
ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THIS IS OUR TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CRANK I GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA
AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
WHY I'M HERE CURRY AYE BERMAN?
BERMAN BONTA COOLEY AYE COOLEY
AYE COOPER.
FOR I DALY. DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS. SO'S I WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BUILDS UP. THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH ITEM FOURTEEN TALKING ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SIX.
AB TWENTY I SIXTY SIX ALLOWS
THE STATE TO FOOT UP TO NINETY
PERCENT OF THE BILL FOR DEAD AND
DYING. TREE REMOVAL AND RURAL
COUNTIES EXPERIENCE THE TREE
MORTALITY CRISIS WE ARE WE IN
THIS LIMITED PASSED THE SAME
BILL LAST YEAR WITH ZERO NO
VOTES.
THE BILL IS NECESSARY TO REDUCE
WILDFIRE PROTECT OUR WATERSHED
THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
CARE SINGLE PICKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE CRITICALLY NEEDED
FUNDING TO AREAS IMPACTED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION WITH REGARDS TO
TREE REMOVAL. AND MANY OF THE
COUNTIES AFFECTED BY THIS
EMERGENCY HAVE DEPLETED THEIR
GENERAL FUNDS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THEIR COST. THEIR SHARE
OF THE COST TO DO TREE REMOVAL.
INCREASING THE STATE SHARE WILL
HAVE FORCED HEALTH BENEFITS THAT
EXTEND WELL BEYOND THE COUNTIES
WHERE THE TREES ARE REMOVED. AS
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES
HAVE TAUGHT US THE NEED THERE IS
A NEED TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE AS A
STATE IN ORDER TO RESTORE AND
HAVE A RESILIENT AND HEALTHY
FORESTS ASTEROID.
STACY HEAT IN RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THIRTY FIVE RURAL
COUNTY STATEWIDE A LOT OF ARE
COUNTIES ARCHIE MORTALITY AREAS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CARE MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUES
ENTERED YOUR STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE STUFF THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROBERT
SIEGEL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
ABSOLUTELY SIR.
COULD COULD LAST.
PRESENTER COME UP FOR.
AB MIGHT WANT TO TAKE A CHAIR.
.
COME JOIN US UP FRONT. AHEAD.
OR YOU.
STILL SOME SMALL DETAIL.
QUALITIES
VALUES.
FARM BUREAU IS PERSPECTIVE.
SURE WELL MISTER BIGELOW I'M.
APPRECIATED OUR BARBARA STRIVE
TO PROTECT IMPROVE THE
AVAILABILITY EXCELLENT POINT I
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY.
YEAH COULD WELCOME TO CHINO
SUSPECT.
ANY OTHER.
BRAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE BRING ABOUT THE
MEMBERS FOR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND DO PASSED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY. AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA I FOR THE
MOST THE AYE AGUIAR CURRY AYE
AYE WORKER AYE.
BERMAN I BONTA.
POLICE AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE. EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA AYE LAUREATE AYE JONES
SAWYER. KILEY. KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE HIGH LOW.
RUBIO. RUBIO I SALAS. SOLIS AYE
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE HAVE OUR NEXT PRESENTER AB.
THANK YOU AB TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
MISTER GRAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA LOTTERY
TO PAY MORE MONEY TO THE OFFICE
WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
KOSTAS.
SALAS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT LAST YEAR I DON'T THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A PERCENT OR IN
SUPPORT. WE DO THANK YOU.
YOU GOT IT.
ROBERT JACOBSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON PROBLEM
GAMBLING.
WE ARE I NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
WERE AFFECTED BY GAMBLING
ADDICTION AND TO RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS.
OUT.
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR A
PARTICULARLY FOR THE INCREASED
FUNDING IT REPRESENTS FOR THE
OFFICE OF PROBLEM GAMBLING.
GAMBLING ADDICTION AFFECTS ABOUT
THREE AND A HALF PERCENT OF
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
MORE THAN A MILLION ADULTS.
IMPACTS CAN HAVE CONSEQUENCES ON
FINANCIAL PHYSICAL MENTAL
HEALTH.
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES TO THE
FAMILY THE OFFICE OF PROBLEM
GAMBLING IS CURRENTLY THE
PRIMARY GOVERNMENT DEPARTMENT.
THAT SERVES THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THEIR CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS OF
ABOUT EIGHT AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS.
ALLOW THEM TO MARKET TO FOUR OUT
OF SIX GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITHOUT AN
INCREASE THEY ARE UNABLE TO
EXPAND THOSE FINAL TWO REGIONS.
OPG IS FUNDING OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS HAS REMAINED
RELATIVELY STABLE.
BUT AS A PER CAPITA BASIS IS THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA
GROWERS.
IT'S ACTUALLY DECREASED BY ABOUT
FOUR PERCENT.
CURRENT FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA IS
ABOUT TWENTY TWO PER TWENTY TWO
CENTS PER CAPITA.
WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW THE
RATE OF THIRTY SEVEN CENTS PER
CAPITA.
THAT REPRESENTS AN UNWEIGHTED
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF THE THIRTY
NINE STATES THAT PROVIDE PUBLIC
FUNDING.
THEY DON'T THAT PRESENTATION
SHE IS VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
WILLING TO.
AND HAPPENS.
ENTER GOVERNOR BEHALF THE
MORONGO BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A
REASONABLE WAY TO PROVIDE EQUITY
AND GET MORE MONEY INTO THE OFF
THE PROBLEM GAMBLING.
WE SUPPORT.
HILL ARE NOT TAKING TIME HERE
FOR THE BROWN ABANDON MISSION
INDIANS AND WE ALSO SUPPORT AND
ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUTHOR'S
EFFORTS TO UPGRADE THE PRETTY
PALTRY AMOUNTS THAT THE LOTTERY
HAS BEEN PROVIDING FOR PROBLEM
GAMBLING SO FAR. SO THANK YOU
FOR THEM.
FOLLOW TREAT ON BEHALF OF THE
COLUSA INTO CHINA TRIBES IN
FULLER WAS TOO NICE.
EVERYBODY SHOULD THAT'S HAS
GAMING SHOULD BE PAIN AND THAT
THIS FINE AND WE'RE VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT.
SHAWN FLANAGAN ON BEHALF OF CHIU
MASINISSA QUAN TRIBE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS.
KILEY.
I REFERENCE TO PRESS THIS BILL I
AM SEEMS FINE TO PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING FOR THIS OFFICE AND. I
HAVE NOTICED THAT THE THE
LOTTERIES ADVERTISING PRACTICES
HAVE GOTTEN QUITE AGGRESSIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE THEY HAVE THIS OUT
PLAY AT THE PUMP FEATURE WHERE
WHEN YOU GO TO PUMP YOUR GAS
YOU'RE ASKED WHAT HE WON BY
AUDREY TICKET. AND YET YOU CAN'T
PROCEED BUYER GAS UNTIL YOU SAY
NOW I WANT THAT TOGETHER AYE YES
I WANT YOU TO KNOW I DON'T.
DO YOU KNOW IF HE'S OFFICES
PROBLEM GAMBLING HAS.
INVESTIGATED AT ALL WHETHER SOME
OF THE LOTTERY'S ADVERTISING
PRACTICES ARE ITSELF
CONTRIBUTING THE PROBLEM.
SURE.
WHILE I DO NOT REPRESENT THE OFF
THE PROBLEM GAMBLING. I DO KNOW
THAT OPG IS AVAILABLE TO CONSULT
WITH THE LOTTERY AND THAT
THROUGH OUR HELPLINE AND VARIOUS
OTHER PROGRAMS WE DO COLLECT
DATA AS TO HOW NEW PROGRAMS MAY
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE GENERAL
PUBLIC.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY OPG
DOES NOT HAVE ANY REGULATORY OR
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO HAVE
ANY IMPACT OVER LOTTERIES
ADVERTISING PRACTICE.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO
INVESTIGATING THE THEY WOULDN'T
BE THE AGENCY THAT COULD
ACTUALLY INITIATE OR PURSUE AN
INVESTIGATION.
OKAY Y. THING IT'S ON WORTH
LOOKING INTO BECAUSE IF WE'RE
USING THESE PRACTICES WHICH I
THINK ARE. YOU KNOW VERY
AGGRESSIVE TO REQUIRE SOMEONE
FOR THE BAG LAST SAY NO I DON'T
WANT A LOTTERY TICKET I MEAN I'M
NOT REQUIRED TO. I REFUSE ANY
OTHER PRODUCT I GUESS MAYBE A
CAR WASH
BEFORE I I GET MY GAS.
SILVER USING THIS IS A WAY TO
KINDA.
HOOK PEOPLE IN THE REASON CARD
THAT REVENUE TO PUT IN THE
PROBLEM OF.
TO THE OFFICE OF PROBLEM
GAMBLING IT SEEMS SOMEWHAT SELF
DEFEATING SO I. YOU KNOW I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THAT THE LOTTERY TO TO
EXAMINE SOME OF ITS OWN
PRACTICES IN THAT RESPECT FOR
LITERALLY MAKES A PRIORITY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF MR ACOSTA.
BOB THANK YOU QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR.
.
BUT AS FAR AS I COULD TELL THE.
THE SOURCES IT REALLY SPECIFY
LIKE WHERE THIS IS BECAUSE
OUT OF THIS
COMING OUT OF THE.
LOTTERY PROCEEDS TO THE WINNERS
THIS IS COMING OUT. MY CONCERN
IS THAT WE
DON'T TAKE AWAY FROM THE SCHOOL
FUNDING CAN CAN YOU ELABORATE ON
THAT A BIT.
OPENED YEARS THREE MAIN SOURCES
OF FUNDING TRAVELS HERE CARD
ROOMS LOTTERY.
THIS ACCOUNTS FOR.
.
ROUGHLY.
LISTA HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS INTO. THE
OFFICE PROBLEM GAMBLING IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
.
ACCOUNTS FOR LESS THAN TWO
PERCENT OF OPG IS ANNUAL BUDGET
WERE CUT CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL
CONSENT CASINOS CONTRIBUTED
NINETY SIX PERCENT.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WERE MOVING SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES HERE.
IN THE FRONT I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER YET UNRESOLVED ISSUES.
THE NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
CERTAINLY WE NEED TO AYE
INQUIRES TO WHERE MR KILEY BUYS
GAS. AND.
ONE PROBLEM CAR WASH IN IN
SUBSEQUENT MEETINGS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
AND SO WITH SOME SERIOUS BUTTON
NOW AND LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE.
SO SO WHY I APPRECIATE THAT SO
TIGHTLY I DIDN'T BEGIN.
THEN A SO THE ANSWER LOOK AROUND
OKAY I'M IN THIS BOOK COULD BE.
FLUSHED OUT BUT NOT IN THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL BUT YEAH SOMETHING
WE CAN ENTERTAIN THREE OKAY WELL
I I'M NOT I'M ASKING FOR AN
AMENDMENTS A SURLY BUT WHAT I AM
ASKING FOR IS IS THAT IDENTIFY
NIGHT IS CONCERNED THAT IT'S
COMING OUT OF SCHOOL SO.
I'LL I'LL LAY OFF THE BILL THIS
POINT TOLD YOU TO TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT AMERICA'S BACKGROUND
FLORA TETRA BUT.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF OF OF THE
BILL A THIS IS HAVE THAT ONE
CONCERN BUT EVEN I MOVE THE BILL
SHOULD TEAR THOSE NOT TO.
I'M OF THE BILL MINISTER MAYBE.
SO NOT TO DIMINISH THE.
EDUCATION FUNDING CONTAINED IN
THE PROGRAM.
BUT RATHER TO ADDRESS THE
SERIOUS ISSUE OF PROBLEM
GAMBLING THAT NEEDS
I ADEQUATE FUNDING AND.
THIS'LL MOVE US IN THE
DIRECTION OF MORE ADEQUATE
FUNDING.
BUT I AGREE WITH THE.
SCOPE OF THE BILL AND IDEA OF
THE BILL FOR YOU.
THE* THAT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS MISTER GLORIA I
JUST MAKE A QUICK COMMENT IN
LIGHT OF THE QUESTIONS REST I
THINK THIS IS A FANTASTIC BILL.
I THINK THAT IT'S OBVIOUS THAT
PEOPLE OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LITTLE GAMBLING A PROBLEM
GAMBLING.
IN OUR COMMUNITY THIS OBVIOUS
WHO DIRECTED JUST RESOURCES TO
IT WILL HAVE IN THE ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT OF PROVIDE EQUITY IN
SOMETHING IS COMPLETELY
INEQUITABLE. OF FROM SOME OF THE
BUSINESSES THAT SERVE MY
COMMUNITY.
AND SERVICE MY DIRECT I G. A
DEMOGRAPHIC COMMUNITY SO I
THERE'S EQUITY IN THIS BILL THAT
SOME JUSTICE IN THIS BILL AND IN
RESULT HOPEFULLY WILL BE. FEWER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE PROBLEM GAMBLING
I I DON'T KNOW THERE'S THERE
SHOULDN'T BE A QUESTIONER DEBATE
THE SHOULD
SUPPORT AFFORDABLE YES MIDDLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF THERE'S NO MORE
QUESTIONS THERE I SEE NO MORE
QUESTIONS.
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT.
GRANDSON AYE AYE.
GRAY I HAVE BIGELOW NOT WANTING.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING ACOSTA NOT
VOTING. ACOSTA NOT VOTING AT
THEIR CURRY.
I WORK VERY AYE BERMAN. BERMAN
AYE BONTA.
I BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I VAGUELY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING. EDUARDO
GARCIA. GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING LIVING.
LEVINE I LOW.
THOUGH I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SO THIS.
SOLIS I WANTED. WALDRON AYE.
THAT DOES NOT MISTER CHAIRMAN
CONGRATULATIONS THEY WERE SURE
IF I MIGHT TO MAKE ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION BEFORE THE TH
DIES.
THAT I THINK MORE DRESS.
DIRECTLY ADDRESSES WHICH CAUSES
QUESTION WHICH IS.
THIS.
SPENDING COMES OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ADMINISTRATIVE
PORTION OF SPENDING WITH AND
WATER OF COURSE WOULDN'T AFFECT
SCHOOLS WHICH I BELIEVE IS WHERE
HE WAS GOING WITH THIS QUESTION.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT'S.
WHAT I WAS INTERPRETING FROM
THIS? OUT OF THE THREE
COMPONENTS THAT MAKE UP THE
STATE LOTTERIES NEVER TO LET.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT YOU MISTER CHAIR
.
JUST FOR THE RECORD ON THE
PREVIOUS BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR MISTER GRAY'S BILL.
STIR LACKEY AND MR ACOSTA.
.
CHANGE YOUR VOTES FOR NOT VOTING
TO VOTING AYE.
FOR THE RECORD TO REFLECT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THEY HAVE ONE FEEL RIPPED. OFF.
THE. QUE MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
YOU.
.
RETURN TO OUR FINAL PRESENTATION
OF THE DAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
HAS TWO ITEMS ITEM SIX.
AND ITEM TWELVE WILL BEGIN WITH
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY.
.
ONE SIXTY FIVE.
MR LOW PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS ELECTION DAY
HOLIDAY.
AND THE MOTION AND THE SECOND
WITH RESPECT TO I WOULD LIKE TO.
TURN OVER TO FILL A COLLEAGUE
TO JUST SAY HELLO.
I'M DOING AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY SPORT YES
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY THE.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
XIN BONTA IN A POSITION OF
CONCERNS WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE MEMBERS OFFICE ON THIS.
DANIEL SO YOU KNOW ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES.
AND.
THERE'S BEEN AN UNINTENTIONAL
LIE INVOLVEMENT OF THIS BILL
WITH ANOTHER UNRELATED BUDGET
REQUEST THAT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR.
RELATED TO WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE
UNIFORM FOR LEVEL HOLIDAY
SCHEDULE TO BE PRECISE. NOW A
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE'VE HAD TO WORK
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
STAFF HAVE BEEN VERY GRACIOUS IN
ACCOMMODATING.
SO WE LOOK FOR DEBT CONTAINING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL ON.
COMMENTS OR TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NUMBER RAY BACK TO.
MISTER KILEY WERE COMPARED TO
THE MEMBERS KNOW HOW.
MISTER KILEY WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION.
STILL GOING BACK. THINGS.
.
MR LEAD YOU OF OTHER STATES HAVE
AN AUDIENCE STATES THAT ELECTION
AS A HOLIDAY.
YES THERE ARE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE LIKE A HOLIDAY.
FOURTEEN OTHER STATES PORTA
RICO.
INCLUDED AS A LIKE ME* SO IS
THERE ANY.
ANALYSIS OF WHETHER THIS
INCREASED TURN ON THE STATE'S
OF THERE IS NO EVIDENCE AT THIS
POINT. THAT I HAD BEEN PRESENTED
WITH THAT DEMONSTRATES THAT.
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK THERE
ARE SOME SPECIFIC.
ANECDOTAL A CONVERSATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO LOWERING THE BARRIERS
TO ENTRY WHICH IS THAT WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT MIGHT
EXIST WITH RESPECT TO
PARTICIPATION. AFTER ELECTION.
AND.
MUCH OF THAT COULD BE ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT LIFE ISSUES
WHETHER IT BE WORKING SCHOOL YOU
GET YOUR KIDS. OTHER SUCH THANK
I UNDERSTAND THAT ARGUMENT WOULD
BE A FOURTEEN STATES THAT HAVE
DONE THIS AND HASN'T
TURNOUT WHY DO YOU THINK WE'RE
GONNA INCREASE TURN UP AND HERE.
I THINK IT'S IN THE SPIRIT OF
LOWERING THE BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION RIGHT BUT IF
YOU'RE A CLEAR FOURTEEN STATES
OF DOT AND HOUSING INCREASE
TURNOUT THE WHITE AND IT'S GOOD
INCREASE TURNOUT WE HAVEN'T DONE
A AYE. WELL LET'S SAY THAT THE.
WITH RESPECT TO A PEW RESEARCH
CENTER. HOW WOULD? THEY DID
HIGHLIGHT THAT WORK OR SCHOOL
ALWAYS THE NUMBER ONE FACTOR
WITH RESPECT TO NON
PARTICIPATION OPENS IN A WAY
THAT WAS TRUE OF THE FOURTEEN
STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY DONE
THIS AND IT INCREASE TURNOUT
SLIDING CAN INCREASE TURNOUT
HERE WHAT IT AND I JUST I JUST
ANSWER YOUR. QUESTION. I DON'T
THINK YOU THAT.
YEAH I JUST I JUST ENTER QUITE
ABOUT LOWERING THE BARRIERS.
OKAY.
BUT I GUESS THOSE WERE NOT
BARRIERS IN THE STATE THAT VOTED
ON THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN.
ALRIGHT SECOND QUESTION
HOW DOES JUDGE WHETHER MY FIRST
QUESTION WAS ANSWERED.
SO WHAT YOU LEVEL TO SAY. I
SAID I'LL LET OTHERS JUDGE WITH
MY FIRST QUESTION WAS ANSWERED
AYE BUT IF THERE HAS BEEN
EVIDENCE THAT THERE'S INCREASE
TURNOUT IN THAT STATE THAT BE
INTERESTING TO SEE. SO
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN MOVING TO
THIS.
VOTE CENTER MODEL WHERE I YOU
KNOW YOU GET MORE TIME TO VOTE
NOW
AND SO WITH I SORT OF ELONGATING
THE.
TIME TO VOTE WHY IS NOW THE
TIME TO GIVE US THIS ONE.
PACIFIC DAY WORLD NOT LESS OF
THE VOTING IS GOING TO TAKE MY
PLACE IS A HOLLOW.
WELL WE'VE ALL BREAK WHERE YOU
ELECTIONS BEFORE I WAS NOT
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE NEVER ON
THE LECTURES CONNECTICUT ON
ELECTION OKAY.
WE'VE EVER ON THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE I WAS IN SCHOOL OKAY YOU
HEARD THIS BILL BEFORE.
DO YOU RECALL
I DO OKAY SO IT'S NOT JUST THIS
TIME IT'S. LAST TIME THIS TIME
EVERY SINGLE TIME THAT WE WANT
TO LOWER BARRIERS TO ENTRY BUT
IF IT IS YOUR OBSERVATION AND
EXPERIENCE
IN CONCLUSION THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE IT HARDER. THEN THAT'S YOUR
PROPERTY.
I AM NOT REALLY SURE THAT
QUESTIONS THAT'S EITHER SO I'M
NOTING THAT WE HAVE AYE.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
MR SALSA.
MISTER CHAIR I THINK YOU FOR THE
JOINT AUTHORS OF PRESENTED ON
THIS I SEE THIS AS AN INCREASE
TO. A DEMOCRACY AND
PARTICIPATION INTO OUR ELECTION
PROCESS. ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO INCREASE
THE LEVEL OF CITIZENS ENGAGING
IN OUR
MICRON PROCESS HE THIS IS A
MOVING TOWARDS THAT. WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AND
ASK IF I COULD BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THIS MEASURE AS WELL
THE AUDITED DELIGHTED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GIPSON.
MISTER BIGELOW.
TO THE AUTHOR MUCH.
HELLO YES AS YOU KNOW ELECTION
DAY IS IS
SINGULAR AND IT'S.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE INTENT OF
THIS BUT
THE BILL IS FOR THE SINGULAR. AS
WE TRANSITION OUT TO THE MORE ON
MODERN. DAY OF VOTING WHERE WE
WILL NO LONGER HAVE POLLING
PLACES WILL VOTE BY MAIL AND
WILL HAVE APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN
DAYS TO VOTE. HOW DO YOU SEE
THIS BILL?
ARE BEING AFFECTED BY THAT AND
THE HOLIDAY PROCESS.
THURMOND.
ABOUT THE TRANSITION OF THAT
WHERE THE TRAJECTORY OF THE
STATE CALIFORNIA'S GOING WITH
RECKLESS OR GOING TO WE HAVE IS
A SINGLE DAY YES AND ALLOW WHICH
EMPLOYERS ARE YOU ARE REQUIRED
TO LET THEIR EMPLOYEES OFF.
DO GOING VOTE.
BUT NOT ALWAYS THAT THAT
OCCURRED AND WE WANT TO
CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE MORE
DEMOCRACY IN THE ABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO VOTE HENCE THE REASON
WHY WE'RE MOVING. TO MORE BROAD
IN ITS STE
SCOPE DOT HOW ALLOW ELEVEN DAY
PERIOD FOR PEOPLE TO CHOOSE TO
VOTE OR GET THEIR BALLOT AND. IN
A TIMELY WAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FOR THE
VERY OF RESPECT. A DIALOGUE AND
CONVERSATION AND RECOGNITION OF
THE CURRENT ELECTORAL PROCESS IN
THIS.
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OF THIS IS NOT ONLY
ABOUT ELECTED AS A HOLIDAY WITH
RESPECT TO LOWERING THE BARRIERS
OF ENTRY BUT ALSO TO CELEBRATE
ELECTION AS A HOLIDAY TO USE
THIS AS A CIVIC MODEL. AND
TALKING ABOUT THIS PROCESS.
SO THAT THAT IS OF FULLY
ENCOMPASSED IN PART OF THE
SPIRIT AT TO HELP ENHANCE THE
PROCESS OF ELECTION DAY.
AND WE'VE SEEN SUCH
TERRIBLE.
PARTICIPATION AND WITH
RESPECTIVOS. AND WHY NOT USE
THIS OUT OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND ALL PEOPLE LIKE TO
SAY WE ARE GOING TO USE THIS
SIMILE AS A HOLIDAY. AND TALK
ABOUT WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
TO TAKE TIME OFF
I TO PARTICIPATE IN EXERCISE
YOUR CIVIC AND YOUR PATRIOTIC
DUTY.
WE'RE GONNA MISTER SOLACE AND
WE'RE GOING TO MISS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE I JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP.
THOSE GERMAN I CAME UP FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND YOU'RE
WORKING WITH HIM ON THAT ISSUE
AS WELL IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW IF
THIS BILL WERE TO BE SIDE ITS
LOS WITH BUDGET REQUEST ACTUALLY
OFFSET FOR OUR DISABLED
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS LETTER.
AFFECTED IT'S WANTED TO CLARIFY
THAT WOULD LEAD TO SOMETHING
THAT YOU ARE WORKING WITH THEM
ON AND. CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM ON WITH THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND ALSO THIS LEGISLATION YES
THANK YOU.
THIS REVIEW.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AS A
FORMER TEACHER.
I REALLY.
.
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WHAT WERE
YOU TRYING TO DO WE DO SPEND A
LOT OF TIME.
IN THE CLASSROOM TALKING ABOUT
THE HOLIDAYS AND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE HOLIDAYS AND
I THINK THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
APPROACH TO.
TALKING TO KIDS EARLY ARE AS
YOUNG AS PRESCHOOL AND.
KINDERGARTEN ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE ABOUT VOTING IN
MAKING IT A HOLIDAY WOULD
HIGHLIGHT NOT JUST AT THE
HOLIDAY FOR ADULTS BUT I THINK
THE TEACHING IN THE CLASSROOMS
WOULD BE.
ABOUT WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT I
THINK WE CAN GROW A GENERATION
OF KIDS THERE MORE AND MORE I
INVESTED IN.
PARTICIPATION SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE OF THE.
BILL FORWARD AND I.
APPLAUD YOU ON YOUR EFFORTS
EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN GET THROUGH THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON THE.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
SO MR LOW I KNOW THIS BILL ABOUT
REMOVING BARRIERS
S. AS HE TALKED ABOUT AND AND I
KNOW.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT
FOR ME TO VOTE ME EVER SINCE I
WAS EIGHTEEN WHEN I FILLED OUT
MY REGISTRATION FORM REGISTERED
AND YOU KNOW VOTED IN EVERY
ELECTION IS SO IT'S BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT BUT I KNOW IF WE DON'T
LIKE TO REMOVE BARRIERS AND I
AUTOMATICALLY REGISTERED WITH.
THE D. AND THE RIGHT.
IT'S IT'S ARE NOT AUTOMATICALLY
IS AUTOMATED AUTOMATED READ IT
AND I'M SO WE TAKE CARE OF THE
REGISTRATION. PART PORTION OF IT
RIGHT WE.
SAME DAY VOTER REGISTERS GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTED THIS NEXT
ELECTION SO YOU CAN REGISTER ON
THE SAME DAY.
AND VOTE AND WE ALSO HAVE
MANDATORY TIME OFF FROM WORK.
YOU CAN REQUEST OF YOUR AND
EMPLOYER HAS TO GIVE IT TO YOU.
BUT TO GO VOTE REYES AND SO THIS
IS JUST ONE MORE.
REMOVAL OF VARIOUS BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY HARD TO VOTE.
AND THE STATE RIGHT.
IS THAT THE COMPLETION OF YOUR
QUITE YET IT IS.
OKAY YET.
SO NOW THE HOLIDAY RIGHT BUT WE
JUST BROUGHT UP THAT NOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE ELEVEN DAYS TO VOTE
RIGHT SO WHY NOT JUST MAKE IT
ELEVEN DAYS.
HOLIDAY.
TO MAKE IT REALLY REALLY EASY.
MAYBE A MONTH OFF.
.
FOR PEOPLE OF THE IS THAT IS
THAT IS THAT AMENDMENT GONNA GET
TO YOUR IS AYE AYES.
I THINK IF YOU ARE GOING IS THIS
LIKE I THINK THAT IT'S ACTUALLY
THERE'S.
IF THERE IS ANY BARRIER THERE'S
NOT AT ALL THE A BUT THIS POINT
WITH WITH ALL THE THINGS WE'VE
DONE TO MAKE IT VERY EASY FOR
SOMEONE TO GOING TO VOTE. TO NOW
ADD ANOTHER HOLIDAY AGES.
WELL WE ALREADY HAVE HOW MANY
HOLIDAYS WE HAVE STATE HOLIDAYS
WE HAVE NO.
I'M NOT PRIVY TO THAT QUESTION
MISTER GALLAGHER THINK GROWTH
FOR THIS SIXTEEN I THINK NOW ARE
YOU ASK YOUR QUESTION WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO ANSWER EXAMINING. SO
YOUR QUESTION WAS.
SPECTER YOU HIGHLIGHTING.
THE CURRENT PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
ESTABLISHED AS A STATE.
TO RECOGNIZE THE SPIRIT OF
LOWERING AS MANY BARRIERS TO
MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE.
AND IN FACT
TO GALLAGHER WE'VE HAD
ADDITIONAL PROPOSALS DEVASTATE
Y. PROCESS TO WHICH YOU DO HAVE.
PREPAID POSTAGE ON DROPS THE
BALLOTS IN MY COUNTY YOU DO NOT
NEED TO PUT A STAMP ON THE
BALLOT. THERE ARE MANY PROPOSALS
SO WE WANT TO LOWER A FINANCIAL
BARRIER THERE COULD BE TWO.
ENSURING THAT ALL VOTES
ARE GOING AND INDIVIDUALS HAVE
AN OPTION TO DO SO.
THAT GOES IN LINE WITH THE
SPIRIT OF OR TALK BACK HERE
TODAY AS WELL.
SO YES THIS IS PART OF A WIDER
PACKAGE OF DIRECTION FOR US TO
ENCOURAGE AS MUCH CIVIC
PARTICIPATION.
I'M JUST I'M JUST QUESTION A
NECESSITY WHEN WE HAVE ALREADY
MADE
SO EASY TO
LIKE IT'S.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT YOU COULD
NOT THAT YOU CAN TRULY SAY ALL
THAT IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO
VOTE ON THIS DAY YOU CAN ASK
YOUR TIME OFF EMPLOYER. YOU CAN
VOTE ANYTIME WITHIN THIS PERIOD
YOU CAN REGISTER AND VOTE THE
SAME DAY ALL THESE THINGS SO I
JUST THAT WHAT I'M GETTING AS A
QUESTION THE NECESSITY.
AND I GUESS MY FINAL QUESTION
WOULD BE WHAT IF.
SHOULD WE STILL GET THIS HOLIDAY
PEOPLE IF THEY'VE BEEN WATCHING
A LOT OF FAKE NEWS.
GETTING THE WRONG INFORMATION
ABOUT ELECTIONS WHO WE DON'T
WANT THOSE. WHO WOULD WANT THOSE
PEOPLE TO VOTE WITH THE WRONG
INFORMATION SO KIM SHOULD BE AT?
SOME KIND OF PROVISION IN THAT
RESPECT WHAT WHAT PROVISIONAL
YOU'RE PROPOSING.
ARE ARE ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT
IF WE IF WHAT IF SOMEBODY'S
WATCHING TOO MUCH FAKE NEWS
WE KNOW.
IN THE IN THE OPINION I GUESS
SOME OF THE LEGISLATURE.
WHO SHOULD THOSE PEOPLE'S ALSO
GET A DAY OFF TO THE THAT THAT'S
NOT WHAT BY BILL WAS PROPOSING?
LET ME LOSER THAT MIGHT BE A
FUTURE BILL.
THIS IS ALL THAT WHEN YOU'RE
POSING NOT THE NOT THAT I'M
OKAY.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT I CAN
EXPECT BECAUSE YOU TO HER GIVEN
LIKE TOP RECESSION THAT TIME AND
THAT WOULD KEEP IT AS TO THE
SPECIFICS OF THIS BILL GO AHEAD
MOVE I THINK THROUGH THE MEDIA.
DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE TWO YOU
THERE ARE A SIXTEEN STATE
HOLIDAYS FOR THE RECORD.
IF ANYONE NEEDED CLARIFICATION
WOULD YOU NOT HAVE A FAKE NEWS
HOLIDAY YOU CERTAINLY CAN
INTRODUCE THAT MISTER GALLAGHER
APPEAR INTERESTED.
IN THE MEANTIME WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND SEE ABOUT THE MEASURE FRONT
OF US WHICH HAS BEEN BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE. IN THE PAST.
AND WE HAVE A.
MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREG AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING ACOSTA NO.
ACOSTA NO I WHERE CURRY. I WORK
VERY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO. EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON ARE
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER. BY
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO LACKEY NO. LACKEY NO
LEVINE.
IT IS THE ANSWER.
LEVINE I.
LOOK I LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS
SOLIS AYE WALDRON.
LARGER NO.
THAT BILLS OUT. MITCHELL WOULD.
YOU CARE TO MOVE ON TO YOUR
SECOND ITEM. ITEM TWELVE.
A. B..
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THIRTY DAYS I WAS IS
A THIRTY DAY LIMIT ON THE AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT BUREAU OF.
GAMBLING CONTROL HAS TO REVIEW A
LOCAL ORDINANCE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I WITH ME TO HAVE A MOTION THEIR
SIGN YEAH ME TOO AND I
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR.
JERRY BROWN AND ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION A CARTRIDGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
STEVE COONEY ON BEHALF OF PARK
WEST CASINOS AND AS A FORMER
CHIEF DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
FOR EIGHT YEARS IN A MUCH
EARLIER HERE AT THIS IS NOT.
A PARTICULARLY HIGHER CUSTOMER
SERVICE BAR SHOULDN'T BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
DO IT.
WE ARCHER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
S. SEEING NINE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS IS THE MOTION
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AND WE ARE VERY.
AND WE ARE VERY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA I BONTA AYE
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I ATWATER GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON AYE
AYE GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY. KILEY
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOATH. LOW I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SOLIS
SO AS I WANTED.
WALDRON ARE.
THE BILLS OUT.
OKAY WILL GO AHEAD AND LEAVE THE
OTHER ROLE OPEN FOR OUR FIVE
MINUTES FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON IN
.
HE
HI THANKS ROBERT.
YOU GET
.
THANK.
YOU KNOW.
I SAW
.
YEAH YEAH YEAH
YEAH YEAH.
NMAA
.
LAST.
THIS BILL
.
ALONG
YOU HAVE.
BECAUSE I WANTED.
THURMOND.
OR YOU. FOR ALL MY. LIFE THIS.
YEAH
NMLS. I THOUGHT IF JANA.
I DIDN'T MAKE.
YOU ARE YOU INCLINED.
I HADNT
.
MICHAEL JOHNSON.
DURING.
YEAH.
HOW?
I HADNT